there's a new version that you're
involved with of Mystery Science Theater
which is classically Mystery Science
Theater people are very happy about yeah
tell us tell us about that how are you
involved and what's going on at this new
show well it's it's bittersweet because
I play the son of TV's Frank that was
was played by the brilliant Frank
Conniff yeah so half of me as a fan of
the show was super excited to get to do
that role yeah but the other half of me
the 22 year old snotty fan of Mystery
Science Theater I can hear his voice in
my head going dad's not Frank Conniff
this guy sucked like I'm very aware of
how I would have reacted when I was a
fan of it now I know how like Tim Ripper
Owens felt when he took over from Rob
Halford and Judas Priest yeah it's like
you just had this this see you know he
had a sea of metalheads wanting him dead
I have a sea of movie nerds wanting me
dead so there's a little I'm a little
tense but I hope that I've had some
experience with this kind of thing
you'll get in there uh-huh
just like twenty-four years ago but I
can't believe it's been that long
there's a period of like who the hell is
this guy and then after about 18 years
of that there's gradual acceptance Wow
so just I stick it out for a decade plus
eight years yeah yeah I'll slowly wash
away the the gold glitter of Frank
Conniff I don't know how I'll be able to
do that I'll do it
you